there are go-to States
and there's no ghost States and no go
States right now are New York New Jersey
Massachusetts California
you cannot invest in those places
Massachusetts is at war with
entrepreneurship Elizabeth Warren will
punish you for Success she will make
sure you pay super taxes if you're
successful the regulatory environment
there is prohibitive for business New
York even worse New Jersey forget about
it California is not in business you
can't do business there and they're
leaving like droves out of there so this
competition of states is beginning to
occur in their right mind right now is
looking at those places and being like
yes I'm going to build a giant Factory
in New York I'm going to employ all of
these people in California as he said
California is just done